um it's clear you have a lot of respect
for ding and i don't know how much
you're keeping an eye on the
developments with the candidates do you
think he deserves that spot if he does
get it in the end i mean i think the
whole question of deserving the spot is
very very difficult since i think he's
clearly the best player who's not in the
candidates at the moment except for for
me maybe who's who's not
a good point
but whether that means that he deserves
it that's
yeah that's a lot a lot harder to um to
say really for instance i mean there are
no
chess reasons why karjakin doesn't
deserve the spot like he qualified but i
understand that
there are other reasons why he's deemed
not to deserve it but i think that that
whole
debate of deserved versus not deserved
is is very difficult but i think to
devise a system
that
makes it more likely that players like
ding are
actually in the candidates would be a
good idea since with the current system
it's really hard for anybody to
to qualify which is in
in a way
more more equitable it makes it means
that more players have had the chance
but if you really want the best players
to play for the world championship then
it's definitely not ideal to to have
these spots from um
from from very very narrow qualifying
tournaments rather than rather than
something like rating for instance which
measures uh performance over over a
longer time so
i mean personally i would of course love
to to see him in the in the candidates
he would certainly erase the um the
level the level there